الكثيره
في خطاب عودته الى سده الحكم التطرق الى
وثيقه خطوط حكومته العريضه
واختار الحديث اولا عن القضيه الجامعه بين
الائتلاف والمعارضه وهي محاربه
مشروعينا لذا ستكون مهمتنا الاولى التاكد
من ان ايران لن تقصفنا بقنابل ذريه
السابقه ووعد بالعمل من اجل العوده الى
الحكم
وقدرات امنيه عاليه وقوه ردعا هائله
ومكانه دوليه هي الافضل على الاطلاق حاول
ان لا تدمر هذا سنعود قريبا
كنيسه الثقه لتنصيب الحكومه الجديده وكى
يصل نتنياهو الى هذه المرحله كان عليه
استرضاء شركائه في احزاب اقصى اليمين
والمتدينين وتشريع قوانين جديده تلبس
شروطهم وتوجهاتهم السياسيه والدينيه
واحتجاجا على ذلك تظاهر 100 الاسرائيليين
خارج مقر الكنيست وطالبوا بعدم منح الثقه
للحكومه يقولون انها ستقود اسرائيل الى
دوله دينيه اصوليه
بدفع اثمان باهضه لبقائه في السلطه كي
يحمي نفسه من محاكمته في قضايا الفساد
المتهم بها
ضد الفلسطينيين وحقيقته كونها دوله احتلال
بالترويج انها دوله ديمقراطيه ولبراليه
لكن مع تنصيب حكومه توصف بالاكثر تطرفا
سياسيا ودينيا واجتماعيا ستزداد التحديات
امامنا ياهو بين سعيه للحفاظ على ائتلافه
الجديد وبين تسويق صوره اسرائيل
كدوله ديمقراطيه
فمع انطلاق هذه الحكومه عبر الفلسطينيون
عن قلاقهم من تزايد اعتداءات الاحتلال
وانتهاكه للشرعيه الدوليه
لاسيما ان خطوط الحكومه العريضه لا تخفي
مخططاتها بتعزيز الاستيطان وتوسيعه وتجديد
قبضه الاحتلال على مفاصل حياه الفلسطينيين
نقلت ايضا الصراع من كون صراع فلسطين
اسرائيلي الى صراع فلسطيني الى صراع
اسرائيلي دولي الان مع تحديها لقرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه خيارات حول التركيز على
رص الصفوف تحقيق المصالح
الفلسطينيون ان ما سبق هذه المرحله لم يكن
بافضل لكنهم يخشون الامعانه اكثر في
القضاء على حلمهم بالتحرر واقامه دوله
فلسطينيه
نسوان سمري الجزيره مدينه القدس